merci Jean-François ils sont de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la
Meurthe-et-Moselle mondiale et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances on va bien sûr longuement
parler des questions budgétaires il y a
beaucoup de textes mais d'abord un mot
on l'a vu dans le journal sur ce qui
s'est passé hier lors des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement puisqu'elle
Isabelle borne a dû répondre à de
nombreuses questions de sénateurs on a
vu ces affrontements ce week-end
blessant des dizaines de gendarmes
Élisabeth borne a dit des scènes
inacceptables et profondément choquantes
il n'y aura aucune impunité elle a eu la
bonne réaction vous partagez ses propos
oui même si j'ai le sentiment que
de manière assez récurrente lorsqu'il y
a des
montées d'extrême violence on a un
maincablement les mêmes réactions des
gouvernements
c'est le moins je crois que ce qui est
derrière tout ça c'est que c'est
ultras finalement ils desservent la
cause de l'écologie quand on n'est pas
capable de respecter même celles et ceux
qui sont a priori les plus proches de
vos idées c'est qu'en fait vous ne
défendez pas des idées vous venez pour
casser c'est la violence gratuite on la
retrouve à tous les échelons de la
société on le voit dans le sport
malheureusement les ultras la violence
et on le voit à la moindre manifestation
on en vient à regretter les grandes
manifestations
syndicales qui se déroulaient d'ailleurs
à la fois dans une forme de bonne humeur
mais également de revendications
aujourd'hui
de nos concitoyens privilégie les
positions radicales d'une extrême
violence ça n'est pas acceptable et ça
doit être effectivement combattu sans
relâche et je l'espère effectivement
sans tolérer la moindre impunité parce
que terrorisme pour vous vous irez
jusqu'à l'impôt vous savez je pense
qu'il faut faire attention j'ai pas le
sentiment que ce soit du terrorisme je
me dis bien j'ai pas le sentiment par
contre j'ai le sentiment que ça dessert
la cause a priori je le redis qui
devrait être servi et finalement c'est
parfaitement contre-productif d'abord
parce que on ne respecte pas je dirais
un processus démocratique y compris
administratif en l'occurrence pour ceux
qui concerne c'est retenu d'eau mais
c'était déjà effectivement la même chose
avec Bruno Retailleau le président notre
groupe au Sénat l'a rappelé avec
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ça suffit je
dirais les hadistes n'ont pas à imposer
contre les administrations contre des
décisions de justice
leur manière d'être et de faire cette
absolument intolérable et il faut lutter
sans merci parce que heureusement la
démocratie doit triompher l'autre
actualité senseena qui va entamer
aujourd'hui l'examen de la Loi sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
avec un tout petit peu de retard c'est
les sénateurs ont notamment introduit
une sorte de droit de veto des mers sur
la construction d'éolienne le
gouvernement n'y est pas franchement
favorable c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire est-ce que ça conditionne votre
soutien à ce texte le fait que figure ce
droit de l'étoile des mains d'abord
c'est un c'est un moment important mais
et le droit de veto je pense qu'il est
aujourd'hui
incontournable en tous les cas c'est une
attente dans les territoires mais je
pense que le gouvernement s'y prend très
mal
on a une crise énergétique mondiale et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que propose
maintenant c'est pas une vaste réflexion
sur les principaux enjeux énergétiques
comment construire l'indépendance
énergétique quels sont nos forces
qu'elles sont nos faiblesses qu'elle
comment dirais-je quelles orientations
nouvelles on doit développer non il
commence par le petit bout de la
lorgnette
par des textes qui ne sont finalement
qu'un des angles de du grand panorama de
la politique énergétique que la France
devrait conduire quand la France a
choisi une énergie décarbonée le
nucléaire pour avoir une indépendance
énergétique et une forme de souveraineté
là on avait une ambition pour la France
y compris en matière d'énergie le fait
d'avoir tourné le dos depuis plus de 10
ans avec les deux quinquennats François
Hollande et Emmanuel Macron je me
souviens enfin il fallait quasiment
baisser la tête on était des ringards on
balayait d'arrêt demain les
gouvernements balayèrent vers demain
tout ce qui avait été construit par
plusieurs générations qui faisaient et
qui font encore je crois la fierté de la
France quel dommage quel gâchis quelle
gatine et en même temps un texte pour
développer l'énergie nucléaire oui alors
il revient dessus mais lentement depuis
le mois de février c'est pas passé grand
chose
je pense que parfois il faut parler
moins agir plus et mieux on va parler
des textes budgétaires et ils sont
nombreux à commencer par le budget
puisqu'on l'a vu Elizabeth borne a donc
déclenché une nouvelle fois le 49 3 hier
sur l'ensemble du budget cette fois les
oppositions n'ont pas laissé d'autres
choix et Elisabeth borne elle dit que le
dialogue construitisme n'était plus
possible écoutez je pense que la vie
parlementaire par le choix que les
Français ont fait de reconduire le
président de la République et de le
mettre finalement sous contrôle d'une
assemblée avec un panorama et des
sensibilité beaucoup de ludiversifier
c'est la c'est le choix des Français ce
choix il faut le respecter mais il est
évident que ça complique la manière
d'agir pour le gouvernement quand vous
avez une majorité relative à l'Assemblée
et bien vous avez besoin que vos troupes
soient omniprésentes avec une difficulté
c'est parfois difficile d'être en même
temps dans l'examen des textes en
commission d'être dans l'hémicycle et
puis ça donne par contre une visibilité
à la seconde chambre la nôtre le Opel
Luxembourg le Sénat dans une forme
d'équilibre où il faut construire pour
donner à en France les meilleures
chances possibles mais justement
qu'est-ce que vous allez en faire vous
de ce texte puisqu'il va arriver au
Sénat dans les prochains jours puisque
sauf surprise l'émotion de censure
seront rejetées qu'est-ce que vous vous
allez faire de ce budget quelles sont
vos marqueurs mais on a prévu de
l'examiner ce budget on s'en est pas
caché vous voyez d'ailleurs que
effectivement sur la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
finalement est le cadre que la France se
donne voilà pour 5 ans et puis sur le
budget il y aura évidemment des
marqueurs Sénats il y aura des marqueurs
oui je pense que les comment dirais il
faut être attentif à un juste équilibre
entre la protection des Français
notamment avec cette crise énergétique
qui est assez inédite il faut pouvoir
donner à la fois aux Français aux
usagers mais également aux entreprises
pour éviter une rupture une cassure dans
la production c'est ça le l'équilibre
c'est de se dire un bouquet énergétique
le plus efficace possible et ça veut
dire que le compromis sera possible au
Sénat il n'a pas été possible à
l'Assemblée le dialogue il sera possible
celle d'un compromis sera trouvé sur ce
texte il faut deux volontés
le gouvernement déclare nouvelle méthode
je n'ai pas complètement identifié on va
voir et pas là pour vous le dialogue il
s'est engagé mais on voit bien que les
textes tels qu'ils sortent l'assemblée
on a quand même une nouvelle arme
aujourd'hui ou un nouveau calibre c'est
le 49-3 qui aux yeux de l'opinion en
2022 n'est plus perçu comme il l'était
parce que c'est un outil constitutionnel
c'est incontestable simplement ça donne
le sentiment d'un passage en force et
d'une qualité d'écoute insuffisante à la
sortie nationale nous sommes nous dans
des dispositions d'esprit peut-être
différentes nous aurons des exigences si
le Gouvernement entend je pense qu'il y
a toujours une place pour le dialogue et
pour construire réussir un avenir
meilleur pour notre pays on en a grand
besoin
de finance rectif c'est le deuxième avec
des mesures pour aider les français pour
faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie notamment un chèque énergie
pour les plus modestes ou la ristourne à
la pompe qui est prolongée jusqu'au 15
novembre ça c'est un texte qui vous
convient
c'est plus c'est plus compliqué qui n'y
paraît parce que on remet par exemple à
nouveau dans ce budget 2 milliards
exclusifs du peu sur France compétences
finalement ça veut dire que les les
prévisions budgétaires ont été
mal jaugés et c'est au long des textes
budgétaires France compétences donc le
financement de cette montée en puissance
mais mal contrôlé de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
pourquoi je dis mal contrôlé parce que
finalement le système de l'apprentissage
et pour partie des loyers est-ce que
l'apprentissage c'est pas d'abord et
essentiellement de permettre par une
voie différente et notamment au début de
la formation au milieu de la formation
quand on a
14 16 ans une voie nouvelle qui permet à
un certain nombre d'entre nous de se
perfectionner de trouver une voie
notamment une voie professionnelle et
aujourd'hui pourquoi je dis que cette
filière est dévoyée c'est parce que
c'est plutôt dans les masters 1 et 2
donc au niveau des études supérieures
oui il y a besoin de faire mais autant
non ça coûte très cher c'est mal jaugé
et quand on nous dit qu'on a le retrait
et que en fin d'année il faut sortir je
le dis comme ça de la poche de milliards
excusez du peu donc
ce que vous pouvez vous y opposer quand
on va les mesures qui sont prises pour
être les Français face à l'énergie
est-ce que les Français comprendrai que
vous ôteriez de tellement bien le sujet
n'est pas de s'opposer sur le principe
mais le sujet par exemple
bien sûr et puis l'échec qui continue de
tomber
de manière comment dirais-je inorganisé
à chaque PLF rectificatif on a droit à
la politique du chèque la politique du
chèque elle est finalement la
reconnaissance d'une mauvaise gestion
oui à une forme de structure oui à des
mesures qui permettent de réduire la
facture énergétique et par exemple quand
on voit l'échec de ma prime rénove voilà
c'est quand on échoue sur ma primaire
bien qu'on y met beaucoup d'argent
derrière on paye une deuxième fois et
finalement on continue de jeter l'argent
par les fenêtres là non plus c'est pas
alors l'étanchéité budgétaire c'est pas
vraiment le choix du gouvernement et
justement se poser la question des
finances publiques à long terme mais
cette nuit vous avez voté la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2023 2027 votez oui mais modifié on va
voir tout ça avec Audrey vitale
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour et Audrey hier
les sénateurs ont donc examiné le la loi
de programmation budgétaire pour les
années 2023 2027 il y a eu des
changements majeurs quels sont-ils oui
un changement de calendrier déjà les
sénateurs sous votre roulettes monsieur
le rapporteur ont mis un coup
d'accélérateur vous avez choisi de
ramener le déficit en dessous de 3% du
PIB dès 2025 contre la vie du
gouvernement qui lui proposait 2027 on
va écouter vos arguments à travers
l'intervention de votre collègue
Christine Lagarde l'avarde suivi de la
réponse du ministre des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal
malgré une anticipation très optimiste
de la croissance le déficit reste de 5%
et ne retrouve son niveau de 3% qu'en
2027 nous serions donc pendant deux ans
les plus mauvaises élèves de la zone
euro mais permettez-moi juste de dire
qu'un tel ajustement
doit pouvoir être atteint de manière
crédible 37 milliards d'euros à trouver
d'ici à 2027 25 milliards d'euros à
trouver d'ici à 2025 par cohérence si
votre assemblée décidait de baisser ou
un effort supplémentaire d'économie de
25 milliards d'euros à horizon 2025 cet
article devra également être amendé pour
dire où c'est où ces 25 milliards
d'euros seraient pris ce qui serait pris
sur la défense sur l'éducation nationale
de manière très générale vous avez eu
des mots très durs pour ce texte d'après
vous le gouvernement s'appuie sur des
projections trop optimistes pour
construire sa trajectoire c'est aussi la
vie de votre collègue communiste Pascal
Savoldelli il a même demandé à ce qu'on
arrête les discussions dès le début de
la séance écoutez
messieurs les ministres je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention et je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de respect
vous n'avez pas le monopole de la
responsabilité
pour faire une phrase qui parle à
certains qui étaient sur le monopole du
cœur à l'époque le Haut Conseil a l'air
que la croissance française est déjà à
son niveau maximal que les réformes
districtuelles de l'assurance chômage et
des retraites notamment ni changeront
rien ou pas grand chose la raison elle
est simple je me répète en France en
France les gens travaillent déjà
beaucoup comme l'ensemble des membres du
groupe communiste républicains citoyen
écologique je crois que nous devons
projeter ce projet de loi de
déprogrammation des finances publiques
c'est un moment solennelle ce débat
c'est le moment de la déprogrammation
des finances publiques je rappelle que
l'Assemblée nationale a rejeté le texte
qui me plaisait ni à la gauche ni à la
droite vous avez décidé de vous en
emparer pourquoi
alors je vais faire écoute dans un
esprit de responsabilité
l'an passé
la discussion budgétaire avait été
réduite dans un contexte de
pré-électoral aujourd'hui les Français
n'attendent pas de nous de rendre copie
blanche et de balayer demain ce qui doit
être construit en matière budgétaire
faire entendre une voix différente c'est
c'est la voix que le Sénat a choisi
parce qu'elle est aussi d'une certaine
manière la voie de la raison quand on
est élu nous il nous appartient de
prendre nos responsabilités la majorité
sénatoriale prend ses responsabilités et
propose au Gouvernement une trajectoire
nouvelle vous savez on avait
l'impression que ça allait être du sang
et des larmes
la trajectoire que nous proposons c'est
ça veut dire 3 à 4 milliards en moins
l'an prochain sur le budget j'entends on
vient de le voir un projet de loi de
finance significative de fin d'année on
met deux milliards au dernier moment en
plus qu'on rajoute sur le France
compétences et puis il y a quelques
instants le ministre de la Santé promet
il y a dix jours parce qu'il y a une
crise notamment des urgences
pédiatriques 150 millions une début de
discussion au ministère ça passe à 400
millions enfin honnêtement la leçon de
la part du gouvernement sur finalement
une majorité sénatoriale qui deviendrait
excessive et même assez radicalement
violente dans ses prétentions je pense
que c'est pas trop brutal
2025 c'est aussi ce que prenait Édouard
Philippe non mais c'est pas trop brutal
pas pourquoi c'est pas trop brutal parce
que les Français attendent aussi de
l'état des efforts aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que fait le gouvernement à peu près sur
toutes ces missions budgétaires c'est du
plus ben écoutez le monsieur plus
gouvernemental les fait Balzen ça suffit
l'État doit faire des efforts et le
travail doit être mieux récompensé les
Français acceptent de faire des efforts
quand leurs dirigeants que ce soit pour
l'État ou pour les collectivités
territoriales montrent également la voie
je pense que c'est ça l'esprit de
responsabilité c'est de retrousser nos
manches j'aimerais dire de cracher dans
nos mains et nous mettre au boulot pour
redresser la situation parce que pendant
ce temps-là la dérive de la dette
continue et justement sur ces efforts
Audrey il y a eu une autre modification
que le gouvernement n'a semble-t-il pas
eu pas vu venir le Sénat a acté la
suppression de 5% du nombre de
fonctionnaires d'État ça représente 125
000 postes c'était une annonce de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron 2017 jamais
appliquer finalement le groupe Les
Indépendants la remise sur la tablière
vous avez émis un avis de sagesse alors
je vais vous reposer la question du
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal il l'a posé hier où est-ce qu'on
supprime des postes je pense que je ma
réponse elle a été assez claire on doit
balayer les effectifs de l'ensemble des
de la fonction publique c'est pas un
gros mot enfin j'ai pris par exemple
aujourd'hui vous prenez le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale qui est le premier
budget de l'État on a de moins en moins
d'élèves et on recrute de plus en plus
d'enseignants et au final quand on
regarde les classements internationaux
le niveau de de par exemple à la fin du
primaire dans les classements pizza on
est en queue de peloton est-ce que c'est
un gros mot que de dire il nous
appartient de travailler sur ce sujet
c'est pas non je prends cet exemple mais
je peux prendre l'exemple dans beaucoup
beaucoup de domaines parce que qu'est-ce
de quoi souffre aussi la France
finalement un excès de bureaucratisation
vous en parler de l'école du des
problèmes écologiques rapportées
finalement un certain nombre de secteurs
de notre société combien de normes de
règlementations d'aller-retour parfois
par des fonctionnaires dont on dit
qu'ils sont trop sourcils oui ils
appliquent des textes qui sont eux-mêmes
trop complexes mais quand on accélèrera
la prise de décision et finalement que
sa fluxifiera les décisions forcément on
aura également besoin de moins de
personnels il nous faut les bonnes
personnes aux bons endroits là où il y a
des il y a aujourd'hui dans certains
domaines trop de personnels il faut
accepter de réduire pour en mettre
également d'autres c'est ce que j'ai
proposé dans une mission de lutte contre
la fraude de mettre plus de personnel
dans les 5 ans qui viennent sur certains
services qui sont des services en plus
nouveau qui ont 5 ans et pour lesquels
au départ le Sénat émettait des doutes
enfin je crois qu'il faut être très
objectif le Sénat qui a également
demandé hier un effort équitable entre
les collectivités l'administration
centrale oui ce n'était pas le cas dans
le texte du Gouvernement qui demandait
plus d'efforts aux collectivités hors
crise vous avez demandé donc que l'État
fasse les mêmes efforts que ses
collectivités la réponse de ministre de
l'économie est intéressante on va
l'écouter séance kalinothérapie votre
proposition consiste à aligner la baisse
des dépenses publiques de l'État sur
celle des collectivités locales moins
0,5 en volume je pense que c'est une
proposition qui est juste et qui
s'entend et qui est honnête
vous avez bon espoir que cette
proposition reste dans le texte final et
puis de manière plus générale qu'est-ce
qui va devenir de ce texte juste et
honnête ça veut dire je signe ou alors
j'ai pas tout compris je sais Bruno Le
Maire trop habile dans l'utilisation des
mots pour qu'il ne tienne pas parole
donc je suis évidemment confiant le
Sénat montré qu'elle était sa volonté sa
volonté est d'aboutir évidemment sur ce
texte mais comme nous venons de le dire
dans ce que j'appelle le parallélisme
des exigences mais comment accepter
aujourd'hui la copine ici à du
gouvernement qui lui seul contrairement
aux administrations locales et de
sécurité sociale s'exonérer
de produire des efforts
ce sera la ligne c'est état collectivité
même sort même effort
oui ça a été donc rejeté à l'Assemblée
nationale vous vous avez voté ce texte
maintenant c'est la Commission qui se
paritaire sur quoi est-ce que vous allez
appuyer
je viens de le dire quelle est l'avenir
de ce texte sachant que les députés les
républicains ont rejeté à l'assemblée
que nous proposons il est une voie de ce
que j'appellerais de la raison en tous
les cas de d'une perspective de
construire ensemble avec celles et ceux
qui veulent et pour ne rien vous cacher
avec nos collègues députés à l'Assemblée
nous avons travaillé chacun ne travaille
pas dans son coin ce temps là je pense
est révolu et en tous les en toute état
de cause ça n'est pas ce que nos
concitoyens attendent ils attendent
c'est la question des collectivités dont
on vient de parler Audrey
proximité il y a la question de notre
économie nous avons nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin d'une économie qui ne
s'interrompt pas sous l'effet de la
crise énergétique et là j'ai le
sentiment on le verra auprès de la
finance que le compte n'y est pas encore
la situation est aujourd'hui pour notre
économie elle va devenir très tendue et
certainement difficile là encore raison
pour laquelle il nous faut être soudé
pour permettre de franchir cette période
qui est évidemment difficile mais
justement on va parler de la crise
énergétique on remercie Audrey à tout à
l'heure on va parler des énergies
renouvelables avec vous dans le club
Audrey parce que c'est le prochain texte
examiné par de Sénat on va parler de la
crise énergétique on va aller chez vous
dans votre région du côté de Nancy on
retrouve Pascal cette charrini de l'Est
Républicain bonjour Pascal merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous le ministre
délégué Roland Lescure étant Lorraine il
a visité hier l'entreprise Ascometal
très dépendante du prix de l'énergie
oui bonjour à vous en plateau ah oui
effectivement ce cometal une série une
série électrique comme le site de cette
forge qui est très gourmand est très
énergivore et
à ce cometal était la première entre une
des premières entreprises avec avec
Arcelor qui proposait Arcelor des
mesures de chômage partiel à ce métal
était la première entreprise à mettre en
place des le travail de nuit pour donc
des mesures défensifs pour adapter à la
à la flambée des coûts de l'énergie
c'est quand même 800 salariés sur les
deux sites quoi avec des horaires
décalés et donc Roland Lescure est allé
on a passé on a passé nos confrères du
Républicain Lorrain ont passé une partie
de la nuit avec lui il a rendez-vous ce
matin avec les organisations syndicales
parce que là ça passe un peu moins bien
et ce matin il doit débriefer les
organisations syndicales sur le site
DASCO et aussi de cette forge voilà et
évidemment il y a sur la table toutes
les toutes les questions toutes les
questions des
des dispositifs d'aide annoncés par le
gouvernement et puis aussi les objectifs
de décarbonate je crois qu'on pourra en
reparler et vous avez une question
Pascal pour Jean-François
la question à Jean-François Husson qui
issu d'un département gère ou la filière
acier et la filière du feu et du fer et
très et très puissante la vraie question
c'est est-ce que est-ce que
Jean-François ils sont considère que le
gouvernement fait assez en matière de
mesure d'accompagnement et de
décarbonation sur une ce qui est
redevenu en Lorraine un secteur
stratégique glacier et le travail du fer
et des métaux
je pense d'abord bonjour Pascal
facialini je pense que la la France est
notamment la Lorraine un pays un lourd
tribu elle a des industrialisation on
voit aujourd'hui que sur ces filières
industrielles on a un savoir-faire qu'il
faut protéger évidemment il faut
conduire le maximum d'efforts pour
permettre à ces entreprises de passer le
cap ça peut passer par des organisations
un peu différentes et ça il doit y avoir
un impact au niveau de l'entreprise mais
si vous voulez ça me fait penser à
Pont-à-Mousson et ça qui lorsque le prix
du gaz à effet flambé a eu sa facture
montée de 700 % j'avais alerté à
l'époque le ministre de l'économie sur
les dangers la fragilité de l'outil
qu'est-ce que le la France préparait
c'est l'arrivée d'un concurrent indien à
Aix-en-Provence aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
on attend encore pour le numéro 1 de la
fonte en Europe on attend encore une
réponse
et Pascal un mot de tourisme puisqu'on
est encore pendant les vacances de la
Toussaint c'est un enjeu important pour
la montagne notamment du côté des Vosges
oui le tourisme le tourisme en Lorraine
est dans le Grand est un touriste un peu
un peu particulier je viens puisqu'il a
accès à la fois sur la nature et à la
fois sur les citations de les stations
des Vosges station qui sont à la fois
sur le versant alsacien et le versant le
versant lorrain alors là c'est un peu
plus compliqué parce que les parcs et
jouent la joue la carte de l'élongation
notamment les spécialistes de la nature
comme les gens de du parc de
Sainte-Croix qui viennent d'acheter la
station de Ventron qui était en
liquidation pour en faire un station été
hiver au sens large avec une autre
vision de une autre vision du tourisme
effectivement les parcs d'attractions
font le plein c'est le cas du zoo
d'Amnéville c'est le cas de la Bresse
une station de ski est célèbre dans les
Vosges qui joue qui joue la carte du bol
d'air avec de l'accrobranche c'est vrai
aussi c'est vrai aussi pour 23
dont les investissements à hauteur de 3
millions d'euros vont en faire
une station écologique c'est-à-dire où
on était il y aura plein d'activités où
en hiver on aura plus besoin de sa
voiture donc c'est vraiment un
changement de paradigme et puis et puis
aussi de de de
d'un nouvel hébergement de nouveaux
usages étaient hiver pour préparer pour
préparer peut-être la fin de la neige et
le fait qu'on puisse plus utiliser des
canons à neige pour aller skier dans les
10 ans qui viennent une petite réponse
de Jean-François ICHON là dessus oui
Jean-François est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut on peut faire mieux
pour accompagner la reconversion du
massif vosgien
je pense qu'il y a pas que le massif
vosgien d'abord il faut faire surtout
ensemble c'est à dire jouer la carte de
la complémentarité de la bonne
articulation entre les opérateurs
publics les collectivités mais également
le secteur privé les exemples
d'opérateurs privés que soit bol d'air à
La Bresse que soit le parc de
Sainte-Croix Harold dont les opérateurs
effectivement se sont placés en Lorraine
sur Ventron mais également à Rambouillet
ils vont devenir opérateur je crois que
là il y a un savoir-faire et aujourd'hui
je prends l'exemple par exemple sur
l'attraction et l'attractivité
touristique nous devons adapter les
levons nous adapter à la demande
actuelle qui demande finalement plus de
respect de la nature également une
meilleure découverte plus on
s'appropriera ses enjeux autour y
compris du tourisme plus on sera
éco-responsable et citoyens engagés
merci Jean-François ils sont merci
d'avoir été avec nous parce qu'elle
saturing
le plus chaud à la Une de votre journal
merci Jean-François Husson on va se
revoir d'ici peu pendant l'examen du
budget merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'avoir